hola bienvenidos a la presentación
acerca de la fórmula cuadrática la
fórmula cuadrática tiene un nombre que
quizás nos da un poco de miedo porque
suena complicado y abstracto pero en
realidad vamos a ver a través de la
práctica que es una cosa relativamente
sencilla y que es bastante bastante útil
para resolver ecuaciones de segundo
grado o polinomios del segundo grado qué
significa eso pues empecemos
considerando algo de la forma 0 es igual
a x al cuadrado menos x menos 6 y me
pregunto cuáles son los valores de x
para los cuales esto es cierto entonces
ustedes quizás ya sepan de algún vídeo o
de su clase de álgebra que lo que se
puede hacer es factorizar el lado
derecho de la ecuación
lo voy a reescribir como x menos 3 x x +
2 el producto de estos dos polinomios me
da este polinomio de acá arriba así que
bien si lo que quiero es que esto me dé
0 me tiene que dar 0 entonces algunos de
estos dos factores o los dos se tienen
que anular pero el primer factor se
anula precisamente cuando x vale 3 esto
se hace cero si y sólo si x vale 3
y el segundo factor se anula
sólo cuando x vale menos 2 ahora bien
gráficamente qué es lo que está
sucediendo pues para ello vamos a pensar
en una función vamos a pensar en fx que
va a estar definida como x al cuadrado
menos x menos 6 esencialmente mi
ecuación original sólo que ahora no voy
a forzar que sea igual a 0 va a tomar
cualquier valor yo simplemente sustituyó
aquí un valor de x y me da un valor esta
función
y qué pasa con la gráfica de esta
función pues digamos que tengo mi eje x
y que por acá tengo mi eje de mi eje fx
entonces la función vale 0 precisamente
en tres o en menos dos lo que eso me
dice es que mi gráfica va a cortar el
eje x
precisamente en en 3
y en tres y en menos dos de los dos que
está por aquí menos dos ahora si yo aquí
sustituyó x por cero lo que obtengo es
cero al cuadrado menos cero menos seis
que es menos seis por lo tanto cuando x
vale cero que sería sobre este eje la
función vale menos seis menos seis de
modo que la gráfica la gráfica debe
verse algo así más o menos
no soy muy bueno dibujando pero serdán
la idea el punto es que encontrar estos
números donde la función se hace 0 aquí
van a encontrar las intersecciones con
el eje x a estos números a los que hacen
que la función valga 0 probablemente
para otro polinomio ya más o menos a
esos números se les conoce como las
raíces o los ceros del polinomio fx
vamos a hacer otro ejemplo qué pasa si
yo quiero que 0 sea igual a x al
cuadrado más 4 x más 4 entonces si yo
factor hizo esto de nuevo como lo hice
acá arriba esto es lo mismo que x + 2 x
x + 2
quizás reconocieron que este polinomio
simplemente es x + 2 al cuadrado
entonces si 0 es igual a esto eso
significa que x tiene que ser igual a
menos 2 en cualquiera de los dos casos
por lo tanto esta es la única solución
a este problema y lo que nos dice es que
la gráfica de este polinomio cortará al
eje x precisamente cuando x vale menos 2
ahora qué pasa si su polinomio no es tan
sencillo de factorizar
consideremos otro polinomio vamos a
considerar ahora el polinomio menos 10 x
al cuadrado menos 9 x más
y voy a decir que quiero que 0 sea igual
a esto entonces quiero resolver esta
ecuación para que valores de x esto va a
ser cierto y incluso si dividiera todo
entre -10 y lo pusiera en una forma en
la que sólo está x al cuadrado menos
algo más algo entonces aún así no parece
que este polinomio se pueda factorizar
fácilmente y es aquí precisamente donde
nos ayuda a la fórmula cuadrática lo que
voy a introducir ahora y esta es una de
las pocas cosas que sí les voy a
recomendar que se memoricen y lo que me
dicen la fórmula cuadrática es que si yo
tengo una ecuación de la forma
por x al cuadrado
v
por equis
+ c
vamos a agarrar el rojo más y todo eso
lo tengo igual a cero
y noten esta es la forma más general que
puede tomar un polinomio de grado 2 si
apareciera algo que tiene que ver con x
al cubo no sería un polinomio cuadrática
y entonces no podría aplicar la fórmula
cuadrática pero bueno lo que me dice la
fórmula cuadrática es que cuando estás
tratando de resolver esto entonces
abraham en principio dos soluciones y
éstas van a ser x es igual a
- d
v
más menos esto puede ser un más o puede
ser un menos las dos son válidas y cada
una de ellas me da una solución por eso
decía que en general habrá dos
soluciones no siempre pero en general
pero bien más o menos la raíz cuadrada
debe cuadrada
de cuadrada menos cuatro veces a por c
- cuatro veces
por c
todo eso está dentro de la raíz cuadrada
y luego todo esto lo voy a dividir entre
dos veces
así que esas son las soluciones a un
polinomio de grado 2 entonces en este
caso si lo que quiero es resolver esto
en este caso
es igual a menos 10
d
es igual a menos 9
a siempre es el término que acompaña a x
al cuadrado b es el coeficiente de x y c
es el término independiente que en este
caso es 1
entonces bueno si sustituyó todo esto en
la fórmula cuadrática
obtengo que x va a ser igual a menos b
que sería menos -9 menos 29 más menos la
raíz cuadrada de b al cuadrado que sería
81 menos 4 veces
cuatro veces a que es menos 10 por c que
es 1
y todo eso dividido entre dos veces
entre 2 x menos 10
ahora bien cuánto es esto menos menos
nueve serían nueve más menos la raíz
cuadrada de 81
4 x menos 10 sería menos 40 pero tengo
este menos así que 81 más 40
40 todo eso dividido entre menos 20
cuánto es esto pues esto es 9 más menos
la raíz cuadrada de 121
todo eso dividido entre menos 20
esto es lo mismo que 9 + menos 11
dividido entre menos 20 así que como les
decía tengo dos soluciones tengo una
solución x 1 que va a ser 9 + 11 primero
me voy a tomar el más entonces nueve más
entre -20 lo que es lo mismo 9 y 11 es
entre menos 20 que es menos 1
y x2 va a ser igual a 9 ahora me tomo el
menos 9 menos 11 entre -20 9 menos 11 es
a menos 2
entre menos 20 esto es 1 entre 10 así
que estas son las dos raíces que tiene
este polinomio de acá arriba sus dos
raíces son menos 1 y 1 entre 10 la
intersección de la gráfica de este
polinomio con el eje x se da cuando x es
igual a menos 1 y cuando x es igual a 1
entre 10 en el próximo vídeo haré muchos
más ejemplos para tratar de aclarar cómo
funciona este [ __ ] que es la fórmula
cuadrática